à la suite de l'exécution de trois
ressortissants soviétiques d'origine
arménienne accusé d'avoir déposé une
bombe dans le métro de moscou
une manifestation de protestation se
dérouler aujourd'hui devant l'ambassade
d'union soviétique à paris parmi les
manifestants on pouvait reconnaître les
philosophe jean paul sartre et andré
glucksmann
se sont essayé de faire une révision du
procès quand tu qu'un procès ait lieu
publiquement
ils sont morts c'est une affaire
entendue mais il faut pas qu'ils meurent
dans l'oubli complet et avec des
déclarations qui ne sont prouvés par
rien donc la première chose à faire
c'est un procès un point c'est sûr c'est
moi